[Musique]
bonjour louis aliot merci de nous avec
nous ce matin en direct sur rt france
avant de parler de ces émeutes on
vaporise de ce nouveau conseil de
défense qui a lieu ce matin mais a
priori pas d'annonce de confinement
attendu avant d'en avant la semaine
prochaine
vous vous êtes contre ce confinement 1
confirmée - si c'est le cas écoutez je
pense que les confinements ne règle rien
il aggrave les problèmes et que en
respectant évidemment un certain nombre
de règles de précaution maximale est
comment les français se sont habitués à
le faire maintenant
depuis le début de la crise eh bien on
arriverait à la fois à concilier
impératifs sanitaires et vie sociale et
économique parce que le danger de
nouveau confinement
ce serait quand même d'aggraver certain
nombre de problèmes pas seulement
économique mais tout simplement humaine
et sociétaux car il y as au sein de
notre population des groupes en très
grande souffrance je pense notamment
mois aux commerçants je pense à tous
ceux que d'un outil de travail à l'arrêt
et puis aux jeunes que nous bien peu
trop souvent et qui dans cette période
là et moi je le vois bien à perpignan et
bien ne savait pas trop se retrouver
dans une vie qui n'en est pas une et
rien n'est proposé rien n'est fait pour
tenter de justement de leur permettre
d'échapper un peu à cette à cet univers
de contraintes permanentes
le gouvernement qui craint aussi est la
contestation alors on est loin
évidemment de ce qu'on a vu précédemment
face à un troisième confinement qui est
de plus en plus difficile à accepter
pour les français est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce que ce qui se passe au pays
bas pour vous pourrait survenir en
france écoutez j'ai vu qu'il y avait un
sondage qui venait sortie ou 5 1 2 % des
français sont pour et donc 50% contre
donc on est très partagée au sein de la
société française
mais c'est vrai que petit à petit avec
l'augmentation de la consommation
d'alcool
l'augmentation je crois
cottereau etc on peut s'attendre dans
certains endroits à des réactions
épidermiques des réactions de ras-le-bol
des réactions d'insoumission même et un
certain nombre de personnes aujourd'hui
considèrent qu' il est presque un petit
constitutionnel de privée par exemple
restaurateurs d'ouvrir son établissement
alors qu'ils respectent les mesures
barrières le milieu culturel
les musées expos m'expliquer comment
c'est plus dangereux d'aller fréquentes
et rusé que de prendre métro ou un
transport en commun aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup d'incohérences les français le
comprennent de moins en moins ils voient
bien qu'ils aient de cacophonie au sein
du gouvernement entre des effets
d'annoncé qui sont contredites le
lendemain entre ministres premier
ministre président et il n'y a pas la
confiance nécessaire pour imposer encore
des mesures restrictives de liberté
c'est pour cela je suis très inquiet
mois de l'avenir de le du confinement si
confinement il y a mais je crains qu'il
y ait effectivement des réactions
brutales d'un certain nombre de nos
compatriotes et il faudra bien faire
attention et tenir un équilibre parce
que sinon nous allons vers des
catastrophes où on va parler des vaccins
à présent avec ses laboratoires qui ont
du mal à fournir l'europe la commission
européenne exige la transparence sur le
nombre de doses produites voyez cet
appel d'ursula vendeur l'a gagné et on
en parle après l'europe investit des
milliards pour développer un vaccin
contre le coc vie 19 et pour créer un
réel bien commun et maintenant les
laboratoires doivent livrer ils doivent
honorer leurs engagements et c'est
pourquoi nous avait préparé un mécanisme
de transparence dans l'acheminement du
vaccin
l'europe est déterminé à participer à la
création d'un bien commun got
or vous parlé de cacophonie loup a lyon
on sait pas vraiment combien finalement
de 12 vont être produits pas produite
combien de français vont être vaccinés
finalement avec l espacement est ce que
l'europe ne s'est pas fait avoir dans la
signature de ces contrats avec fire ou
astrazeneca
il ya 31 millions de doses seulement qui
seront livrés par exemple sur les 80
millions initialement prévus par
astrazeneca
écoutez je pense de toute façon que
l'europe aujourd'hui c'est le ministère
du blabla tout ce qui est entrepris par
l'europe ne sert strictement à rien et
l'échec est là mais madame van der leyen
ferait bien de se l'appliquer à elle
même ce devoir de transparence car je
rappelle que les députés
les parlementaires européens qui ont
demandé un éclaircissement sur les bons
de commande sur le coût des vaccins et
sur les études qui ont été faites et
bien on tue j'allais dire un
réponse une fin de non recevoir
ou alors avec des contraintes de rentrer
dans une salle sans prendre le téléphone
portable et ses règles et à bref moyens
que cette europe elle est opaque
cette europe elle est technocratique
cette europe elle est aujourd'hui
totalement incapable de faire face à la
crise que nous subissons
c'est bien pour cela qu'il faut que
chaque nation retrouve sa liberté sa
souveraineté non seulement en matière de
commandes parce que là pour le coup on
voit bien qu'ils aient un problème mais
aussi de fabrication de médicaments et
de fabrication de vaccins et les échecs
que nous avons aujourd'hui
malheureusement au sein de l'industrie
pharmaceutique française européenne
trouve qui a un très gros problème
français et européen et qu'il faut
évidemment donner allez dire une
nouvelle stratégie à l'industrie en
france et notamment à l'industrie
pharmaceutique
nous étions avant des leaders sur 7 sur
ce marché-là mondiaux et nous sommes
aujourd'hui malheureusement à la traîne
notamment des américains mais pas que et
je trouve ça absolument emblématique de
cet échec européen qui nous précipite
vers la désorganisation de total et de
même peut-être vers le chaos
allez les pays de l'union européenne qui
on le voit ferme également
progressivement leurs frontières
à l'instar de l'allemagne qui veut même
interrompre les vols vers son territoire
est ce que c'est la levée d'un tabou
finalement écouté c'est surtout
l'assurance que nous avions raison avant
les autres puisque dès que nous avons
eues
nous les premières informations sur la
gravité de la situation notamment la
chine on avait demandé déjà de contrôler
les frontières voilà de contrôler les
aéroports de contrôler un certain nombre
de points névralgiques d'arrivée de
population extérieure l'idéologie
européiste et européenne empêche de le
faire
et monsieur macro ce gouvernement et
même une partie de la droite d'ailleurs
qui est contaminée par cette idéologie
ont toujours milité contre
et bien aujourd'hui maintenant que
l'épidémie est là maintenant qu'il ya
une gravité de situation et tout le
monde le voit bien
eh bien on en vient à des règles que
nous aurions dû mettre en place il ya
déjà longtemps
voilà ça c'était typiquement la
responsabilité de notre gouvernement et
du président macro qui passait il ya
encore quelques années pour des gens
très compétents et dont on s'aperçoit
petit à petit et bien qu'ils ne sont
incompétents dans pas grand chose et que
malheureusement ils mettent en péril la
cohésion
il met en péril l'équilibré ils mettent
en péril l'économie de la nation
et ça c'est dramatique et j'espère que
les français aujourd'hui prennent bien
conscience de cela car il ya des
élections qui arrivent et ces élections
il ne faudra pas les manquer parce que
ce seront peut-être les dernières où le
peuple français pourra peser sur son
destin autre sujet le ministre de
l'intérieur qui a menacé hier de
dissoudre le groupe génération
identitaire gérald darmanin s'est dit
scandalisé après une nouvelle opération
de ce mouvement contre des migrants à la
frontière espagnole
on écoute le ministre de l'intérieur
j'ai donc demandé au samu smith
intérieur de réunir les éléments qui
permettraient aux ministres at her 2
proposera des solutions de génération
identitaire je sais que le ministère y
travaillent
il le fera évidemment dans le cadre
doigt les dérèglements de la république
en proposant notamment une fois que ces
éléments seront particulièrement réunit
le contradictoire est dû à chaque
association et si des éléments sont
comme je lé fais pour les autres
associations que j'ai proposé en
dissolution conseil des ministres réuni
je n'hésiterai pas à proposer la
dissolution génération et dans les
terres comment est-ce que vous
interprétez cette menace de gérald
darmanin dit et moi je ne suis pas un
adepte de ce mouvement de génération
identitaire mais encore une fois je ne
vois pas où est la violation de la loi
c'est un fait un comité de vigilance
précisément de l'immigration clandestine
et de la passoire des passoires que
constituent les frontières françaises
et j'allais presque dire aujourd'hui
c'est plutôt une vigie c'est un
porte-voix une alerte plutôt que
mouvement qui violent la loi
alors évidemment ça peut surprendre
évidemment les bien pensants ces prix de
la salle on voit sa politique pourquoi
dit il ça aujourd'hui politiciens parce
que on voit bien qu'ils mettent beaucoup
plus d'action et d'ardeur à lutter
contre ce genre de mouvement qui est
totalement neutre et pour le coup
pacifique qui ne le fait avec un certain
nombre d'organisations islamistes
présentes sur notre sol et avec lesquels
finalement il s'accommode de la
situation et la dernière
la dernière actualité en a de tous le
montre le peu concernant le fameux
burqini et la décision du défenseur des
droits en l'occurrence la défenseur des
droits qui est en contradiction totale
avec les chartes dite républicaine
laïque et c'est que le ministère tente
de mettre en place un moment donné faut
juste avoir du courage il ya la
constitution française
il y à il ya les lois de la république
et tous ceux qui veulent s'affranchir de
ces lois de ce règlement est bien
doivent tenir compte de cela et s'ils ne
sont pas contents de vivre en france eh
bien ils peuvent aller vivre ailleurs
c'est ça le fond du problème
mais évidemment monsieur darmanin lui
tente de ménager la chèvre et le chou et
à ce petit jeu là précisément ce seront
toujours les extrémistes qui
l'emporteront merci beaucoup louis aliot
d'avoir répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur arte france